welcome everyone
thank you for joining us for our
presentation titled cancer advocacy
it is my pleasure to introduce you to
lori dennison
and shirley mertz lori is a 12 year
breast cancer survivor
patient advocate and breast cancer
research advocate
lori has volunteered as a pink ribbon
mentor served on the join the journey
board of directors for five years with
three years as president
and currently works to advance breast
cancer research as a member of the mayo
clinic breast spore
shirley mertz is a breast cancer
survivor who works with multiple patient
advocacy groups including
serving as the chair of the metastatic
breast cancer alliance
and the president of the metastatic
breast cancer network
shirley has been honored by the white
house as a champion of change
in breast cancer and was named by the
susan g komen foundation
one of the 35 global individuals who
have made a significant
impact in the fight and breast cancer
for a complete biography on our speakers
please visit the biography tab at the
top of your screen
please join me in welcoming lori
dennison and shirley merks
i will now turn the presentation over to
them
thank you so much for having us today
it's a true honor to speak to you
as indicated my name is laurie dennison
and i'm here with shirley mertz
shirley and i met because we both serve
as a patient advocate for the
translational breast cancer research
consortium or tbcrc
we would like to start by sharing our
breast cancer stories
as we represent a couple different
perspectives
from from more of an early stage
perspective and surely from a metastatic
perspective
after sharing our stories we would like
to turn our discussion more to the
future
so i will start out um with my story
and please bear with me because i am
going to read most of this this is
actually an article that i wrote um
shortly after my breast cancer diagnosis
it was a day just like any other day a
june morning and i was
and i was up at the crack of dawn
scurrying to get to work because i had a
million irons in the fire
i arrived about seven a.m to try to
sneak in an
extra hour before a full day of meetings
kicked in
only to realize i had the dreaded
mammogram appointment at 8am
i had already rescheduled it several
times and i knew i had to just
get it over get it over with so i
rescheduled a few meetings and headed
over to my appointment
much to my surprise i was in and out of
there in 45 minutes
that wasn't so bad i thought to myself i
can actually make my nine o'clock
meeting
shortly after 11 the familiar sound of
my overworked pager went off
instead of the usual client concern
about a computer
issue it was a nurse calling me about my
mammogram
she said i needed to come back for more
pictures i wasn't surprised because i
had a nodule of of normal normal breast
tissue
um for in my left breast for about 10
years
i remember snapping back to her back at
her well
it's not going to happen today because i
have a full schedule
bless her heart she calmly responded
with something to the effect that i
shouldn't be alarmed
but that it was important for me to make
the time for this appointment
so i rolled my eyes sort of over the
phone and took a deep breath
and exclaimed this happens every year
after a bit more arguing i agreed to go
back that afternoon
later after several mammograms and
ultrasound and scheduling
a return appointment for a biopsy i
headed home for the day
this is ridiculous i thought it's the
same round slippery soft
movable large grape i've had for 10
years
i don't have time for this little but
little did i know it had nothing to do
with the existing nodule
a few days passed and thoughts began to
race in my head
they had always assured me that this
nodule was normal breast tissue and
wouldn't likely turn to cancer
but what are they seeing could things
have changed
what if it's cancer i don't know the
details but my grandma had
had cancer when i was a child i bet
that's what it is
oh no i do have cancer
this time i couldn't get my biopsy of
get to my biopsy appointment fast enough
it was an ultrasound guided biopsy and
the two women performing the test were
so nice to me
reassuring me that everything would be
fine
they were they were just going to take a
couple small biopsies and i would be on
my way
well 12 small biops punch biopsies later
and it still wasn't clear if they found
what they were looking for
or not they kept looking at each other
pointing at the ultrasound screen and
saying
do you think that's it it was the it was
then that i
realized they weren't looking at the
existing nodule
needless to say i was a wreck i knew in
my gut it was cancer and they didn't
find it
i left the appointment and called my
sister sobbing
they didn't find it i know i know it's
there and they didn't find it
a week went by with no results i
couldn't stand it any longer so i called
the clinic to see what was going on
my physician was on vacation so her
nurse called me back with the results
that the biopsies were normal
she said everything was fine and that i
should schedule my next mammogram in a
year
as i usually do while this was good news
instinct told me that it wasn't right
and that i needed to follow up with my
position when she returned from vacation
the following week
much to my surprise i received a call
from my position
early and
personally to discuss my biopsy results
she had the same concern i did
the tissue found in the biopsies was
normal breast tissue
and didn't match what she expected to
see on the mammogram
or the ultrasound we both agreed that it
needed to be pursued
further she made some calls and was told
that the previous biopsies
would need to heal for three months
before further
testing could be done a follow-up
mammogram appointment was scheduled for
september
and that was the longest summer of my
life waiting
september finally rolled around and it
was back to the drawing board i had
another mammogram
an ultrasound and an mri the good news
was that they
they did finally find it the bad news
was that there was now three spots
instead of one
and the largest one was now invasive
at that point i was diagnosed with grade
one erpr positive
tubular carcinoma in my left breast
ironically just adjacent to the prior
bob's biopsy site
the main tumor was approximately one
centimeter in size and the other two
were pretty close to the chest wall but
much smaller
and so the journey began the next three
weeks were a whirlwind filled with tests
and decisions
the details of which i don't really
recall much anymore
my only option at that point was was
mastectomy
but i did need to decide on a single a
single versus double along with
reconstruction
options after much research and several
discussions with my
pink pink ribbon mentor i decided to go
with a double mastectomy with silk
with with silicone implants i remember
being so
relieved to finally have a diagnosis
with a plan
to move forward and kick and kick this
cancer in the butt
i also remember the invaluable
piece of advice from a physician in the
breast clinic that remind that that i
remind myself
daily she said for you this will be a
two-year interruption in your life
there will be ups and downs along the
way but if you keep positive
it will and take one day at a time you
will get through it
and that was the turning point for me i
put my life in the capable hands of my
physicians
and did exactly what they told me to do
the next two years were were definitely
not a picnic they were
multiple surgeries a couple infections a
cracked rib
expansions of implants and a few other
minor setbacks but all in all things
went very well
there was no lymph node involvement so i
didn't need
chemotherapy or radiation the closest
i have come to winning the lotto
so that's my story and i i will turn it
over to shirley for her story
wow lori i just have to say um
your story certainly exemplifies the um
anguish with which patients feel when
they go through this process
the long wait for results the worry
um it was very beautiful story
and i agree with you it's it's hard to
tell but it does have
meaning to other people especially other
patients
so my story um goes the span of 29 years
i have been living with breast cancer
for 29 years
and i should say not only do i live with
it but my family
i have a husband and two sons
in my mid 40s or early 40s i heeded the
call
to the importance of getting a mammogram
even though
my family had no history of breast
cancer and in 1991
calcifications were found in my left
breast and a lump
a biopsy was done
and the pathology report showed that
indeed it was
breast cancer and that it was erpr
positive i at that time
lumpectomies were newer and i was told
that i could
have my breasts removed or i could have
a lumpectomy
i chose like you instead to ask for a
double mastectomy
and because i viewed at that time that
that might be
bring me closer to her cure because i
didn't want to deal with breast cancer
again
and so although my at first my surgeon
was reluctant
that was my choice i did not choose to
have reconstruction
at that time and i have not had it done
since then
at the conclusion of my surgery when i
met with my uh
surg surgeon again he said shirley you
are
cured go on with the rest of your life
and wow my husband and i heard those
words he wrote them on a piece of paper
and he hung them up in the bedroom so
that we could look at it
i have to say though i had my doubts i
thought
was the surgery enough what if some
little cancer cells slipped out
so i went to the oncologist that was
associated with the hospital
and said how about if i have something
else and she said what do you want i
said well how about chemo
and she said that's ridiculous no she
says you don't need anything else
so i try to calm myself and go on with
my life and my career
and um i
went for 12 years with no
return of my breast cancer and then in
2003
i did feel a pain in my rib cage
i went back to my internist and i
mentioned this and she said well let's
do a bone scan
so a bone scan was done
there was nothing wrong with my rib cage
but instead there were three suspicious
spots
found on my spine so
a biopsy of my spine was done
and the pathology report came back
and this time my
the pathology report said that my
metastatic disease
was hormone negative erpr negative
which i thought wait a minute it's
different from early stage
and i also got the news from my
internist she said surely i'm sorry to
tell you these things
but you probably will live only one or
more to
one or two more years i can't tell you
how shocked i was i was frozen in the
chair
and then i decided i had to see what i
could do
and make the best of my situation i was
referred to
a community oncologist who
i found out later treated patients with
breast cancer
and also gastrointestinal cancers
his decision was to treat me
as if i still had hormone positive
breast cancer and i said why it says
the pathology report says hormone
negative
and he said well first of all um bone
does not um uh biopsy well
and he says um i i've i really think
that you're still
hormone positive well being a good
patient
i said okay and i started taking
arimidex which he recommended
the only other thing that he said to me
though that was uh
startling was he said you need to take
this for a year
and then i will scan you again to see if
it's working
i said a year he said yes hormone
anti-hormone agents take a long time
so six months went by i happened to be
seeing a new primary care physician and
told him of my situation
and he said shirley you can't wait a
year to find out if your treatment's
working
she says he said i'm calling your
oncologist
so he called him and a pet scan was
ordered and on that pet scan the results
were
that my entire skeleton was lit up and
uh there were three lesions in my liver
that lit up on the pet scan i could not
believe it
i was shocked i was scared i cried
it was friday when i was told
by my oncologist that the these were the
results
and he said but i do want to see you on
monday
and we will start chemotherapy to attack
this
i thought long and hard over that
weekend
i had been raised in a working class
family
to respect teachers to respect religious
leaders
and doctors and to do what they say
but this just did not feel right that i
just go
jump into chemotherapy so on monday i
let them know that i was not coming in
for chemotherapy
and i decided to get a second opinion at
a comprehensive cancer
cancer center in chicago associated with
the university
and i met an oncologist there
who treated many metastatic breast
cancer patients
and i in retrospect i found out that
that's a real important point for
patients to realize
she ordered a biopsy of my liver
and pathology report came back and said
indeed my cancer was
erp r negative and it also showed that
my cancer was
her2 positive so my cancer had indeed
changed
from my early stage in 1991.
the doctor suggested and i
totally agreed that i would take zlota
and uh chastisemab or herceptin
and after eight weeks of the loader a ct
scan was done to see how my
treatment was working and it showed that
my liver lesions
were reduced by 50 percent so i was
hopeful and we continued and that
regimen
was continued through april of uh
2005 in fact it was april 1st
when a pet scan showed that there was no
evidence of disease in my body
i mean that i remember the fellow
associated with the oncologist who said
i can't believe
that you are have no evidence of disease
because of
as much burden of metastatic disease
that you had
well i was elated i felt blessed i knew
i was not
cured and i did my doctor said i'm going
to take you off the zeloda
and continue with the herceptin but i
now had hope for the future
real hope and i decided to give back
to the community by becoming a patient
advocate
speaking to patients finding out more
about research
and my story to them was a biopsy
is very important pathologists are very
important
although we rarely ever see the men and
women
who deliver those important results
and a second opinion is important
especially a doctor
that treats a lot of metastatic patients
as well as one that's associated with a
comprehensive
breast cancer center and finally i urge
patients when i
advocate to find out about their breast
cancer
and and learn as much as they can
because
knowledge is power so from 2005 to late
2013
as i followed this regiment i had
regular physical exams
and i was asked questions about my pain
level
whether i had new symptoms how was my
sleep
and that was always pretty bad and what
was my
anxiety level uh every three months
and i have to say that's really often
though four times a year
i had pet scans a few ct scans
but mostly pet scans were used to follow
my care
i had cbc counts
comprehensive metabolic panels but
during this time
i certainly never was offered any tumor
marker tests
i was made aware that if i continued
these pet scans i could be opening
myself up to more cancer
because of the radiation and i really
wish
then that there was something simpler
less complicated than pet scans
that could help monitor my disease
and then in 2014 a pet scan revealed
uptake in a lymph node in my upper
left clavicle area it was biopsied
it was metastasis and the pathology
report this time
showed that my tissue in that
lesion was now estrogen positive
so i am unique and this only happens i
think to about 10 or 15 percent of
patients
but my cancer had mutated again so
surprise
um but now uh in addition three other
diagnostics were done
uh i was given a ca15-3
tumor marker test and the tissue from my
lesion lymph node uh was genomically
tested
to find out what um what kinds of
mutations i had
and i was given a genetic test to
determine if i had
a germline brocco one or bronchi
so since 2014 my
cancer 15-3 tests have been given to me
every four or five months it's been made
clear to me though that
tumor marker tests are not good for
everyone
uh no treatments uh changes are made
just on the basis of a tumor marker test
but for me they offer some comfort um
and for some patients that i've talked
to they do reflect a change when their
cancer gets worse
but for others they're useless um
as as to imaging i do get pet scans
still
but only twice a year they certainly
have become
more difficult to get approved by
insurance carriers
and um and as to the lymph node that i
had
because it was too deep to be removed
without
opening up my chest area i chose to have
it um
ablated through stereotactic radiation
and of course now i'm taking an anti
estrogen agent
for my disease so i think i mean that is
my story maybe a little bit too much
detail
lori but i think that given
your story and mine and
the the understanding that we both
experienced we've both had
with waiting for results worrying about
results
and still like for you wondering will my
cancer come back
even though you've you've taken a very
aggressive stance
as i did we just don't know and so what
do you think
you would like to see uh different in
the future
for people like us yeah
um so i think you know it we've both had
i think for diagnosis
and um you know ongoing
mostly imaging i think
imaging has been been the big thing so
expensive
and um the um insurance companies like
you said you know they don't want to pay
for it you know when i
when i was diagnosed and took the um
the mastectomy option with plants
they actually told me that i would get
um
uh mri every two years just because they
wanted to monitor and they couldn't do a
mammogram
anymore and you know i was i was pretty
excited about that even though it was
quite invasive
but but i felt like somebody was gonna
be you know there was some way to
monitor
uh where i was at and whether i would
you know have a reoccurrence you know
i think that's the biggest gap for me
right right there
is is you know i finished i had my
mastectomy i had my
um um my um
implants and then they kind of said
you're cured
you know you have you have a five
percent chance
of reoccurrence go live your life well
that's great but for me i worry
every day because you know i there's no
there's no monitoring or anything like
that that could catch
you know that could catch a recurrence
it's just me you know looking for lumps
or fi
you know uh responding to pains you know
like you did shirley
um but i think we you know we need
something simpler we need you know like
a simple blood test or something that we
could
get on a yearly basis to to just look at
you know is there any activity in the
body
and if not that's fantastic you know i
think
you know we need something that the
insurance companies won't block that and
even if they do
we could probably you know afford afford
something like that you know and and so
i guess
i guess for me um
in secondary you know one once something
is
really suspected that that's probably a
really good diagno
diagnostic tool but you know
for that for that time period
where um you know you don't have
anything suspected and you just want
reassurance or you want to catch um
you know the ability really to know you
know
is there activity do i need to be
concerned about something
so that you can have peace of mind and
just you know kind of go on with your
life
right right and i think from what i've
learned
that um a blood test
uh has been developed in some other
cancers
where it does up for a poor
uh that this you know an individual
patients
may be having um maybe getting breast
another cancer in the near future uh i
don't know if there's anything
perfect yet but biomarker tests
would certainly make a difference uh in
the early stage setting like you have
been you've been treated you've been
told
you know you're fine right now but that
ongoing
uh i was once told by an oncologist so i
heard him
in a presentation say say the only way
a woman is really cured of breast cancer
is until she dies of something else
yeah right it's kind of depressing to
think about but
the point is we have tests for diabetes
we have tests for psa my husband
recently had prostate cancer and his
psa levels were followed well women are
worthy
of that also and men because men do get
breast cancer
but i think there's more research spent
on
um biomarkers that could be obtained
from blood
uh there's certainly i sometimes just
like you i've sometimes waited a week
for the results of my pet scan and that
is a
week i mean you try to distract yourself
and think about it
i used to do what i i called authorized
okay if they tell me it's going it's
worse what am i going to do then
and i finally got the point to say
surely straighten up and think about
what if it's good news you know you're
right
identify if we are progressing
um and then you know then steps can be
taken
i think the worst that thing that
happens
is to find out that we have breast
cancer when there is a heavy
burden of it because that's hard to
treat when it's
you know spread all over or especially
to catch it earlier than that right well
i think reach
uh you know if if doctors could um and
right now i did a little research for
this presentation
and i'm aware that asco and nccn and
esmo
do not you know recommend regular tumor
marker tests
i think because like i said they vary
among doc
doctors the usage varies among doctors
and then i have spoken to many patients
with metastatic disease
and some will say oh my tumor marker
test
really helps me follow my breast cancer
progression
others will say wasn't any good for me
didn't show a thing
and then still others say my doctors
don't even use them
so there isn't clarity in the clinic if
i could use that phrase
about tumor marker test and i think um
that they could um you know things need
to change
and i'm hoping that people who are
listening to this
to us will say yes this is worth doing
right yeah i mean i think you know uh
the word one of the worst things you
know okay we had breast cancer
um you know for me i'm i
you know hopefully i'm cured you know
they they told me i was cured
go on your you know with your life but i
still worry about it every day
you know i think um earl went right out
of treatment
they said uh you know i mentioned this
in my story that you know they said
you know five percent you know go ahead
live your life you're good um but now i
hear
i think i think there's been you know
some changes in the awareness that at
the 10 to 12 year mark
actually the cancer that i had which
they said was
the one of the least likely to reoccur
you know right out of the gate in 2008
they're now saying is one of the higher
ones to reoccur
and so you know that gives me uh you
know just
a lot of stress every day and so if i
just
had that and i and i have no follow-up
actually right now
i don't have mammograms i don't have
mris i don't have pet spins
i don't you know i don't really have
anything i don't even have doctor's
appointments necessarily
and you and i don't have that dress
right and how could we have been
followed right then
which we don't regret i never regret
removing my breasts
no no me either because i really you
know it did give me peace of mind from
being able to um that i did everything
that i
you know that i could but but i do um
you know i i'm having increasing stress
now
um now that i'm at the 12 year mark and
i hear
you know more about the recurrence um
you know even you know you said you know
you were at the 12 year mark
um that you know that something like
that you know could happen and if i
if i were able to just you know go in
once a year have some sort of a simple
test and then
you know either yes there's activity as
there isn't you
one of the things that often happens to
me
is that because i know many metastatic
patients some of them
will pass away and then of course it's
like worrying about appearance i get
nervous i think oh my god you know death
is around the door
but what what what i told myself
and i've learned over the years is that
every one of us
is a unique patient we all have a
subtype we have different comorbidities
we have different genetics
so you are unique and even though you
read something about the 12-year
you know danger time except remember
that no one else is like you
so uh your situation uh be optimistic
that it it won't come back but that
doesn't mean that you and i don't want
the people listening to this
recording to do something to help the
breast cancer community both
early age and metastatic to
pursue better biomarkers so that we
know about our cancer and we can have
the reassurance earlier
and give our give our clinton some
options
of you know yes and i and i sometimes
wonder to you know if if the biomarkers
wouldn't have helped diagnose mine
because you know we relied on mri which
definitely showed you know it lit up it
showed that i had
you know a spot but then when we did the
um when we did the biopsies they just
missed it i mean it was a smaller cancer
and they and they missed it i mean no
fault of theirs they they just missed it
with the needle
um biopsy but but i just wonder
if you know in combination with with
those more you know invasive
type type tests and scans if if
something like a biomarker you know
blood test or something like that
could have said yes we do see activity
in you know in there there is cancer in
there
and that we could have looked further um
before
it progressed and even though i i still
i feel like i was still lucky because it
was
early enough um you know by the time
we did the second batch of testing but
it's still
you know it had become invasive i had
three tumors now
that had advanced that were you know
close to the chest wall
and you know um um by our um
um
where they what's it called um anyway so
i had
mastectomy was my only option put it
that way
a lumpectomy was not an option anymore
for me but you know i feel like that
in combination might have been able to
catch something that the physical test
you know did didn't didn't rush them
well this has been delightful to get to
know you better
laurie yeah i both want to thank
abbott for the um time that they've
allowed us to not only
share our stories with each other but
share our stories with
those who are attending uh this
conference
and i wish you a great day and i hope
that
this uh covid 19
goes of gets uh a solution so that you
and i
can once again be uh you know tbc rc
meeting
right right right thanks lori so much
yeah thank you yeah and you know i'll
just
i'll just you know as a few uh ending
comments too you know
there's always there's always a little
good with every bad
um you know and i i feel like my life
has changed forever
um but i am alive and active and i and i
really would appreciate um some way to
not have to worry about every day i mean
i feel blessed
you know that that i didn't get as far
as i got
um i just turned 58 yesterday
and i'm super excited about that even
though i think
at one point i wouldn't have been very
happy about 2058
but yeah it is far worse
every year is a blessing um and
you know i i do feel like i was probably
given
you know a second chance to live life to
the fullest and
and i really um want to be able to
do that without worry and you know
i i just think like the best the best
gift would be
to have some way to easily check
um an annual blood test or or whatever
you know it could be um to just for that
little bit of peace of mind
um to go on with my life and
live it to the to the fullest without
all that
and as you said you know i i feel like
the
people watching this are the people that
could help make that happen
so i i can yeah we're
one of the same line great to be right
yes you too thank you be well
right
ladies thank you so much for sharing
your touching stories
um i do have a few questions for you if
that's okay
um shirley i hear that most of the tests
you've had were imaging how did that
affect your physical
and your mental health well
so far physically i don't believe that
all the radiation i have been exposed to
has
resulted in another cancer though i
clearly have been told
that that does uh happen and so that has
kind of been a another thing in the back
of my mind but i
try to put that aside because i don't
have any other alternative you know it's
like
okay choices a or b or or nothing
so i go with the imaging and
as far as my mental as i
try to allude to in my story um
it's it's i dread to schedule an
image i dread to schedule a pet scan
but then i get say to myself are you
just gonna let this come back
without even knowing it so i make the
appointment
i go in there and get it done and then
there's this weight
to get the results it's just oh
and then you know you worry you imagine
the worst
so it it is mentally draining and of
course
i have a husband and two sons that love
me dearly and
and they're on pins and needles because
they don't want to lose
their mom their wife um so it it
it's it's difficult the imaging but but
until 2014
um when i was introduced to the
ca 15-3 tumor marker frankly i
you know i had never had one done before
and um
and so that has brought me some comfort
even though i've been told it's not
perfect uh but for me it has had some
um reaction to the time when i had my
recurrence
in my lymph node and then it's gone back
down
and i watch it each time and i usually
get it done right when the
pet scan is going to be done so i can
think okay how's it looking and
what might i expect but so i hope i've
answered your question
yes you did and this question is really
for both of you
do you wish that you've had a magic
blood test a non-invasive test
that would have been able to catch the
cancer at an earlier stage
of course of course
yeah you know i could start with that i
guess um
you know for me um i i think
that a blood test a magic
blood test you know a magic wand if you
want to call it that
um i i really feel like it
may have helped diagnose mine earlier
i you know there was a period of three
months in there where
my cancer had um you know to grow
and to advance because you know we
didn't find it on the imaging uh you
know and the biopsies before
so you know i do feel like if there was
some
blood test they they could have done in
combination with some of those
you know tests that would just take you
know a little bit different angle at it
um or even you know they called me back
with my results and said
you're good you know go go you know go
about your life
um schedule mammogram in one year if i
would have waited one year you know it
had advanced quite a bit in the three
months that i had to wait for the
healing
and if i would have had a blood test
or or something um i i mean
if my magic if i had a magic wand i
would have a blood test
it's simple it's fairly inexpensive and
you know you can get the results quickly
um
and it's pretty non-invasive so yeah i
do
wish i had that
shirley do you have anything to comment
well i think
in terms of uh the imaging that i've had
and i didn't
make this point when you asked the
original question
um the financial cost of imaging
is growing and
the pushback is coming from insurance
carriers
who are saying you know women are more
attuned to their disease
and they are going into their clinician
to say
uh well how am i doing and how they know
how i'm doing
could i have another test because that's
all we can ask for
at this point um until we have a
definitive blood test
i mean the tumor markers right now are
not
definitive or able to be used uh in the
way that we've been
wanting them so the pushback has come
from insurance carriers
there's more burden than financial
toxicity
to the patients uh because they either
have co-pays
or sometimes it's not approved at all
you may have had one and they say well
you're only allowed one a year ah well
you're going to pay for another one i
mean
those are not cheap but so
really really we need research
um we can call it magical but we need
focus
on research to develop a biomarker for
the monitoring of breast cancer whether
in the early stage or in
the metastatic stage hopefully again
breast cancer and can i interject you
know one more time because i
um i didn't think of this until now but
you know
i think it would be super helpful for
younger patients well
you know i was in my early 20s when they
found the
benign nodule that i had and they they
monit they watched it
um with a mammogram you know um
and and i was in my 20s so normally you
know i was way younger than a normal
mammogram
yeah you know the age for a mammogram um
and and honestly i was 42
when i was yeah when i was diagnosed
with
with can't know i was 50s 46 i'm sorry
when i was diagnosed with
breast cancer and that's still younger
than
you know a normal mammogram um you know
we're getting into mammograms so
had i not had this benign nodule
to begin with that they were watching i
would have never had the mammogram to
begin with
and so in a younger patient like that
you know i had this benign module but
but with a blood test or something much
similar i
they may have been able to follow me um
you know in younger patients you know
and i'm also
um a part of a pink ribbon mentor
group that mentors newly diagnosed
patients and we are seeing
so many now you know in their 20s
in their early 30s and they're you know
they're
they're finding them and they're in
their um
more advanced cancers because they don't
get regular mammograms they're waiting
to find that lymph node or that lump
and that kind of thing and if we if we
had um
access to blood tests and tumor markers
and you know
we we could probably find some of these
earlier in
earlier stages as well so
i i just feel like that that may have
helped me even
you know follow follow me when i was
younger
lori i bet you i think you would agree
with this if we can find a psa
a biomarker for men's prostate cancer
why can't we
find a women's
breast cancer come on you know we
deserve this
just like men deserve to monitor
their disease and even cola guard you
know cola guard is another example i
know that's not a blood test but
it's it's a non-invasive way
to predict you know um
[Music]
uh colon cancer so you know there's
no it's not a hundred percent
people are fearful of that yeah but
nothing which is what i'm
you know being monitored for right now
thank you so much um shirley
you mentioned that tumor markers helped
you in your second
um fight for battling cancer can you
explain
how that impacted your treatment journey
well since uh i had my first tumor
marker that you're mentioning
in 2014 after the lesion
the lymph node was found to be
metastatic and
up till that time i had not had any
lymph nodes involved
um i have the tumor marker antigen done
regularly i'm not obsessive about it but
i would say
three times a year and it really makes a
difference
in my mental um
well-being i mean that it comes back
within
i would say 48 hours i can look on my
chart
and see the result and you know that's
you have to have a under well under 30
is
considered normal uh i but anyway so i
watch that and
they even give you you know a decimal
point you're 5.7 or
whatever 5.9 and it just brings comfort
to me and
i mean i know i still have to face the
image uh imaging but
uh it's helpful and um i i really
appreciated that
i was entered my clinician was willing
to uh suggest it
um she told me about the limitations
but i still find it um very helpful to
me dealing and you know i've been
dealing i just finished
in august was 18 years living with
metastatic breast cancers
it's a long time to worry about when is
the shoe going to drop
and that's about what you know if we let
ourselves think about it
uh it's it's it's daunting so we have to
be
busy about our purpose and enjoying life
and making helping others when we can
and laurie what gives you peace of mind
every day knowing that this ugly disease
isn't
active in you again and what would you
wish to change if you could
yeah i think um you know i
um i decided early on that
um you know after the physician told me
this is an interruption in your life and
i think for me
um she said it's a couple year inter
inter um
interruption in your life you're going
to get back to your you know your life
with your type of cancer we caught it
early
um we're gonna do everything we can and
um
you you know you you'll live a long life
she told me that
um and so honestly i i still
bring myself back to that when she um
when she told me that just to give
myself peace of mind you know
um i did you know have the best
treatment i could have
um i had also had a hysterectomy a
couple years before for some
um some abnormality and um
you know that helped as well cut the
estrogen seeing that my
cancer was a an estrogen gesture and
positive cancer so
um you know there's so many um things
that
that point to the vet you know i'm i'm
good and i i should just
live my life and i can't you know i
shouldn't worry about it every day
but i will say that i'm a worrier and
um as much as i have chosen to be
um happy about it and to move on with it
but i've also
addressed it head on so i i feel like i
um i've become a pink pink robin mentor
um i um mentor newly diagnosed patients
i help them i help give them hope
because they can see that i
you know got through cancer and i'm
living a normal life which is hopeful
to them i'm also you know a patient
advocate
for research so that i'm also giving
back there and help
trying to you know and hoping to help
the research
further the research in breast cancer as
well and i think the only missing piece
for me
is is really some way um like we said
you know
magic wand it would be a simple blood
test i could go in
you know one even once a year multiple
times a year i don't know what you know
whatever was determined
but just for that just for my own peace
of mind
to say yep everything is still good and
then
i could just go on you know doing good
things and helping
others and and living a happy life but
i am a little bit of a warrior and i do
need a little bit more peace of mind and
right now
um i'm not mean being numbered at all
you know only just my own
monitoring and um i i fear
that by the time i find something or
there's a pain or there's a
a lymph node that it will be advanced
and
yeah that would that would just be the
frosting on the cake
it's just to have that base in mind
thank you again lori dennison and
shirley mertz and thank you for sharing
your incredible personal journeys
and for that outstanding discussion we
hope you found today's presentation
inform
informative and insightful this
presentation will be available
for on-demand viewing don't miss out on
our other valuable presentations on our
agenda
visit the agenda tab in the auditorium
for a full listing
thank you again for your participation
until next time
goodbye bye